قالت صحيفه الواشنطن بوست ان المخابرات
الاسرائيليه دفعت الولايات المتحده الى
قطع تمويل المساعدات لغزه بسرعه على اثر
اتهام عاملين في الاونور بالمشاركه في
هجوم السابع من اكتوبر ونقلت الصحيفه عن
مسؤولين ان واشنطن لم تتحقق بشكل مستقل من
مزاعم اسرائيل وعلقت بان الادله التي
قدمتها اسرائيل اقنعت الولايات المتحده
وثماني دول مانحه اخرى بوقف تمويل
الاونروا وهو قرار حذرت مجموعات الاغاثه
الاخرى من انه يعرض سلامه ورفاهيه
المدنيين في غزه
للخطر من جهتها قالت صحيفه الفاينانشال
تايمز ان سحب تمويل الاونروا قد يؤدي الى
وقف عملها في غضون اسابيع والفلسطينيون هم
من سيدفعون الثمن واشارت الصحيفه الى ان
وكاله الامم المتحده لغوث وتشغيل اللاجئ
الفلسطينيين اونروا نجت من عده حروب سابقه
ومن علاقات عدائيه مع مختلف القاده
الاسرائيليين والامريكيين وكانت منخرط في
مهمه غير مسبوقه بايواء واطعام مئات
الالاف من الفلسطينيين الذين شردتهم الحرب
في
غزه صرح رئيس الوزراء الفلسطيني محمد
اشتيه لصحيفه نيويورك تايمز بان الرئيس
محمود عباس والسلطه الفلسطينيه يتعرضان
لضغوط هائله من قبل الشعب الفلسطيني الذي
يريد منا ان نفعل شيئا ويريد منا ان نطلق
حربا على اسرائيل حسب قوله واضاف ان
الانتفاضه الثالثه ليست مستحيله وان مستوى
الغضب الفلسطيني الى جانب عنف المستوطنين
يجعل الوضع قابلا للاشتعال وقال شتيه ايضا
ان اسرائيل فقدت توازنها والاسرائيليون
يتصرفون بروح الانتقام ويقتلون من اجل
القتل في مقال بصحيفته ارت سير الكاتب تيز
فيبريل ان الحرب في غزه لم تعد تهدف الى
الانتقام لمقتل 1200 اسرائيلي او من اجل
الرهاءن بل اصبحت حربا مقدسه من اجل اعاده
توطين غزه فمن شاهد مؤتمر العوده الى غزه
الاحد الماضي يدرك جيدا حسب الكاتب ان
الحرب تهدف الى تصفيه حسابات جريمه
الانفصال عن غزه عام 2000
ويترتب عن ذلك ان الحرب ليس لها ثمن باهظ
في اعتقاد
كثيرين ختاما كتب ديفيد روزنبرج في موقع
المونيتور ان الحرب على غزه ادت الى
ارتفاع حاد في مشتريات الدفاع الاسرائيليه
وقال ان احتياجات الدفاع المحليه في ضوء
الحرب الجاريه اجبرت مقاولي الدفاع
الاسرائيليين على تاخير تنفيذ عقود
التصدير في الوقت الحالي واضاف الكاتب ان
الوضع الاقليمي غير الامن على نحو متزايد
لن يترك للحكومه الاسرائيليه خيارا سوى
انفاق المزيد على الدفاع في المستقبل
المنظور كما انها عازمه على تقليل
اعتمادها على الولايات المتحده في الحصول
على الذخائر
التقليديه